but i was in it early like in terms of
just
being comfortable with it you know i
didn't even fear it you didn't think it
was going to [ __ ] your money up
no i didn't but you know at one point at
one point the record companies did gas
me up
you know they did gassed me up and i was
down here in front of congress like yo
i'm not sure
i'm sir [ __ ] that like like like because
i was gassed up and
you know understanding that that that
that they were just trying to hold on to
some [ __ ] that was gonna go away anyway
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
[Music]
all right everybody uh as many of you
know listening to this podcast i've been
thinking about doing more
interviews and when i was thinking it
through
and thinking about who do i want to get
on who who have i not been able to
really chop with
because you know two planes in the night
everyone's moving fast
this man came first to mind i hit him on
dm
he said let's chop it up and a couple
weeks later we are here
recording on a saturday the legend that
is really the only thing that comes to
mind when i get to say
truly you know i think these days you
know kid has one good game in high
school and they call him the goat and i
laugh
but i you know those hyperboles get
thrown around but you know being 45
growing up in jersey for me ll cool j
is on a different status it's exciting
to kind of
grow up in life when you're in the same
general age and reach
of age because you get to watch the
whole manifesto
thank you so much for doing the podcast
how are you how's your family first of
all before we get into
a bunch of different [ __ ] my family's
well um
you know um healthy thankfully um i'm
having a weird thanksgiving had to call
some close friends and tell them
um not not this not this year we had to
break with
with tradition which wasn't fun but i
think it was the right thing to do
um and um you know we're good you know
what i mean how's yours everybody good
on your end
everybody's good let's go everyone's
good let's go right into it because we
don't have a lot of time and i want i
want to get into a bunch of stuff so i
was born in the soviet union
and when i moved to america we moved to
rigo park
queens you know those are old stomping
grounds for you what did
what when you think about your childhood
forget about parenting dynamics family
dynamics which are obviously
number one two and three for most people
but i spend a lot of time thinking about
environment
when i go there when i say like things
that weren't you know obviously your
parents your
grandparents those are life situations
but the person you're neighbors with
the first kid that you connect with in
second grade when i think about
when you think about your childhood the
neighborhood the activities of the
neighborhood
or the serendipity of classmates or
teachers
what comes to mind outside of immediate
family of things that shaped you
well what i think about my neighborhood
in the way i grew up um
it's a combination of a few things um
it is it's this is a really complicated
answer i'm going to give you the
the real you can tell i want to i want
to go like
different stuff that i think might bring
people value because there's so much on
on
wax and video of you and we'll go into
that stuff but
i like thinking about random [ __ ] and i
was thinking about this morning
i was like i'm just curious like i think
about robbie turnik eric godfrey
i think about like you know jersey
culture was like very like
you know just out the outside it was at
the 80s right like it wasn't video games
yet it wasn't
you know computers and things that
nature i always think about how that
shaped me
the randomness of my neighborhood
friends i love those stories yeah
my my neighborhood was um was really
built around
there was only one dad on the whole my
whole block
um well there was two it was only really
two fathers in households
um which was uh and my grandfather
um which was um that was one
dynamic um
the other dynamic was uh a lot of guys
coming home from jail
and [ __ ] right like so to come home from
jail thing
the fathers come from jail no not
fathers but kids
like 18 to maybe maybe my age or a few
years older
coming home from jail was a lot of
people or like that was a big one
growing up people will always come witch
which incredibly enough
made me want to be physically fit
because you see guys coming home
jacked jack benches in the yard
you know so there was that right then
there was the
there was the um the hustlers
you know there was the the idea of now
mind you
i grew up in a book i mean a house full
of books right and my grandfather came
over from barbados
and um you know he you know he was a
member of a masonic lodge he was a
he was a really kind of evolved guy
um but um you know then you go outside
and it's kind of like yeah
like a thoughtful very very thoughtful
very um
you know uh kind of knew how to give you
and
he knew how to give you it's like giving
a cow enough pasture you give somebody
so much freedom
that they can't hurt themselves it's
like if you have enough land
you can let your dog run wild right you
can let your cow just go crazy because
it's
if it's safe there's nothing so he would
give me a lot of intellectual and
psychological freedom he didn't put a
lot of
you know they didn't like handcuff me
mentally you know what i mean
which so that made me curious and it
made me want to search
you know i've always had a searching
personality because curiosity can be
passive it could turn into wonder or you
could turn in
it could become searching did you fear
to let
him down no
no i didn't i you know it's it's funny
um
you know my grandfather when i was when
i was a kid he used to call me a genius
all the time he said you're a genius
he's a genius this kid's a genius all
the time
this kid's a genius huh
i don't know if i ever really believed
it but you definitely want to live up to
those standards right
it's a lot better than being heard
you're a [ __ ] loser 100 percent
you know and and we both know people
that grew up in those environments and
everybody listening right now people
know and i think a lot about
you know parenting of how like tearing
down buildings or building up buildings
and then the question is
where's the line of delusion and
uh and do parents or grandparents create
ramifications when you don't do genius
[ __ ]
well see i think i think with that part
of it the key is that
that that you can
you can you can have great aspirations
great visions great dreams great goals
but you also have to think
um strategically but then you also have
to think about tactically
what you're gonna do to get there and um
a lot of times the reason why people
have that that that big chasm that they
can't get across is because they're not
thinking about
how they're gonna now look you know
there's an old saying
um plans get um um get shipwrecked
shipwrecked by the laughter of the gods
right but
a lot of times people don't have that
they don't um
they don't take that step they don't
take you know the steps necessary to get
to the greatness
to get to the high level of success
which has a lot of pain
a lot of frustration there's fear
there's there's hecticness there's
nervousness there's anxiety
you know what i mean a lot of times
people they don't deal with that
right yes i mean people people want
all the accolades they don't want the
[ __ ] that comes along with it which is
why they don't get there because they
don't have the stomach for it
100 100 and so like so my grandmother
and grandfather used to always tell me
if a task has once begun never leave it
till it's done be thou labor greater
small
do it well or not at all so what that
did was
it gave me the spirit of completion and
and intestinal fortitude
and stick-to-itiveness you know what i
mean like sticking to [ __ ] how old were
you when you thought you had a shot to
do something
different different eight
great answer why do you remember i just
was walking around i was just
i remember just walking in front of my
house and saying you know just i'm eight
years old and i could i could do
anything and i believed it
who'd you look up to at that point
outside of your family your great let's
see whether grandfather or something
like something out there like uh
was music already on the radar oh you're
yeah i know this right your grandfather
had some music
jazz or something right music yeah he
was a jazz musician and um he
he played a lot of jazz records you know
even more than he
was always around but did you look up
was it was sports on a pedestal
acting anybody in culture yeah you know
bruce lee bruce lee that's a good one
amen that makes sense
let me get your age your age group that
makes a lot of sense he was
huge he was huge he was the man and it
was like
you know quite frankly he was the only
guy he wasn't white
so i could kind of relate to him like
i'm like right he's not black
but he ain't white so at least something
he's a little tan
i can kind of go with this i can make
this work
you know what i mean a lot of people
don't realize how big those kung fu
and movies were because there wasn't
that much there wasn't cable and those
movies would pl
i even remember early early 80s how old
are you
i'm 52. so i'm 45 so seven years old
yeah so if yes so you were 14
13 13 14 15 if i'm thinking about the
era when i
when it hit my radar but i'm sure it was
playing before then yeah like
they would play on like saturday at 11
a.m
when i'm eight nine from from age around
eight nine ten all the way up to maybe
15
that was all martial arts during that
era that was all like
you know from the early 70s on up to
like you know that was all i was a
little babe like a
baby boy and that was all that martial
art it was like
martial arts craze it was like you know
everybody was kung fu fighting
yeah okay it was songs out it was
it really but the thing about it is
getting into martial arts like my
grandfather put me in martial arts i
took sado karate
and i um years later i took some etuan
and i took a little wing chun you know
were you good at
a little bit a little bit yeah growing
up my grandfather got me into it because
they wanted me to
they wanted they wanted it for
discipline but the real reason is
because
i wanted to play football and my
grandmother thought football was too
dangerous
so i could have a physical outlet but
not be getting my brains like
shook is is that why you needed to act
play a football player in a movie you
needed to get that you needed to get
that off without a doubt
get out of down 100 i hadn't lived yet i
had to live that out
i had to i got to play in dallas stadium
i know what it feels like i had i got to
i got to be out there did you grow up a
football fan
oh 100 i grew up you know i grew up a
dallas cowboys fan yeah because they
were always on tv too
i grew up a dallas cowboys fan and um
you know but
but then obviously as i got as i matured
i became a giants fan you know what i'm
saying once i got like it at that point
where i could kind of make my own
decisions
because my grandfather kind of guided me
to the cowboys he was real funny
too because this is a guy who came from
the bronx he's in queens but he likes
the yankees
so i'm watching the yankees and
everybody in my neighborhood is like
match fans and [ __ ]
but then you know what i mean but then
like and they're like
jets and they're jets fans and i'm
liking the giants it was crazy
the jets and giants neither team made
the playoffs in the 70s
so there's a lot of new york you know
people that kind of like gravitated
towards the
cowboys the steelers the raiders during
that era
yep which i never understand because i
love rooting for bad teams because i
love loyalty
i love neighborhood i love eating [ __ ]
but a lot of people don't want their
sports frustrating them which i
understand
like if sports is an outlet for your
life
who the [ __ ] needs more headaches you
know you're trying to escape your
headaches
you're absolutely right gary and i
understand the lord loyalty i really do
but it's just hard to be loyal to
like that's
so let's talk about music when does when
does that even hit your radar as
i'm gonna do music um when i was
i started writing when i was around 11
or around 12
11 12. so at about 10 11 there's all the
martial arts stuff we talked about and
then there's the music right and
hip hop is flooding the flooding um the
street
do you remember the first time you
understood there was a different
thing what was it was it did they call
did the first time you heard it did was
it
hip-hop did they use the term rap did
they
what what was the term in that very
interesting question initially i mean it
was hip-hop but but
we didn't really call it that like it
was more i don't remember it was
more about rap music and rhyming you
know what i'm saying like
i remember beatboxing that's a human
beatboxing but it was like rap it was
like rap you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah rapping and and then rhyming
as well as we got more sophisticated
because you know the guys
you know like guys that i got with we
all thought about
like the couplets the content the
cadence
the you know all of that and that's when
it came more about rhyming
what was the first hip-hop song
that hit you hard well it wasn't even
well it was um it was some of the cold
crush brother
routines you know it wasn't even on wax
the tapes i was actually because i i
used to go between queens and north
babylon
you know what i'm saying every year like
i lived in queens i lived in north
babylon long island queen's north
babylon queens northbound because you
were going between what
my mother and my grandmothers understood
and so
um you know so i would you know but
there was a lot of foster kids
in the house next door to me in long
island going back and forth or you would
spend the summer or how did you do it no
no i would literally
all of the above i would go to school
back and forth and summers back and
forth and be
back and forth during the summer and
like hard
or hard like like literally every other
year
like you know and was that hard and was
that was hard for you
or do you think you or at the time hard
and now you're like oh that's why
i can adjust the [ __ ] was it kind of
just it's all you knew and it just
that's what it is and didn't really
think twice no it was did you enjoy it
did you like like coming back and
like you know kind of interesting
believe in that company it was just up
to his life
no todd's a pain in the ass so he's
gonna go to long island this year up
okay he's good he's good oh he's really
painted ass now let's set him back to
queens
oh any any any time that you would move
into like dangerous
zone they thought a reset resets
interesting it would hit me with the
reset
[Laughter]
do you think now do you think now
that enable like what if i said you what
did you
gain out of that maybe there's nothing
maybe there's a ton i just
yeah i believe in i think adversity well
it it it gave me exposure right because
the first time i walked in a classroom
in long island you know you got to
remember i'm going from a school that's
i would say 99.99 black
you know other than you know like and
other than my
my friend richie who's jewish who who
was like my who would like who's like
eight nine years old who's my jewish
friend everybody's black right i got one
jewish friend
and everybody's black and rich when she
has been part of my school
where she doesn't go to my school
richie's my family friend
because my aunt is a school teacher and
her best friend and
linda you know and so me and richie are
cool so other than richie
it's all about but then when i go to
long island i walk in the classroom
it's the exact opposite right or the
inverse it's everybody's white
and i'm like the one there's one black
kid and i walk in and i'm
i'm the black kid you know and maybe
there's another one and it was like i
remember my eyes like you know
jumping out of my head but what it did
was it exposed me to different people
right because you know you know you go
you go to quit you go to long island at
that time you had a lot of
italians coming from brooklyn moving to
long island you know what i'm saying
so you you you're meeting so i had like
italian friend and then
you you kind of find out also just irish
friends but then you find out about the
racial dynamics that i didn't know
existed
when i was in queens you know what i
mean so that was
did it come at you hard in long island
or did it come in
medium or you would say subtle because
people were
cool you coming you know it's subtle you
know two kids will be talking and you'll
walk in on them and they'll be saying
something they shouldn't
saying and then no they'll be saying you
catch them saying something they should
be saying and they
they get quiet you know but it wasn't it
wasn't like
atrocious nah it wasn't atrocious man
because
new york is like yeah i agree well new
york is funny in the sense that
you know in jersey for that matter too
right in the sense that yes there's a
lot of
there's racism but it's so there's also
jokes there's also a
a rivalry and a fun there's a it's
different in new york you know what i
mean
like people i know exactly what you mean
i'm 45 50 dude like things weren't as
politically correct
so there was exactly i remember like
people would make racial jokes across
the board i mean
i caught a very weird time because i
was russian when the ussr was the evil
enemy
so i got real heat because we were in
the cold war
kind of like kids after 9 11 right were
from the middle east like
like russia shot down a plane in third
grade
shot down a commercial plane and
literally my class just decided not to
talk to me for the week
wow like we were the enemy and so i
don't talk about it a whole lot because
it's like
out of context now people don't
understand but like 1982-8384
you know that go watch rocky like russia
was like the enemy and
people i mean people called me spy every
day
you know like like every day they're
like you're spying on us
you know like and people think it's
funny people
fought a lot i think about fighting a
lot i think fighting has
like is different now like i feel like
it's extremes
it's either no fighting going on in the
suburbs or that
exactly or extreme [ __ ] and every week
day i'm on instagram seeing something
that
breaks my heart but like when i i mean i
was since
i was in a lot of fights kids were
always fighting there was a lot of
fights well
i definitely grew up i grew up you know
in the knuckle game heavy like
you know that's all i did growing up
like a lot of it was a lot of knuckle
games
you liked it no i didn't like it per se
but
you know when i was younger you know i
was slim
and i had that kind of face that you
know you want to try
i don't know pretty but you know like
they just it's still pretty
i wasn't like you know i didn't have
that that look so they
seemed scary so they thought they could
come up on you yeah yeah so i used to
have to put some uh put some of this on
them
you know i mean but uh you remember do
you remember
what let's call it from 6 to 16
the best feeling in the fight and the
let's talk about stories that people
don't know like
like i'll give you mine in second grade
there was a kid named oded weinstock
who came from israel and just decided
that we were rivals we fought
three times between second and sixth
grade and it culminated after school
with
literally a hundred people watching
because he caught me earlier in the day
pushed me into the locker and like got
on top of me
and that was it they broke it up we went
to detention but at lunch
i just hear the whole lunchroom in sixth
grade saying oh that beat up gary and i
was like man i can't this i can't
this can't be my reputation we just got
to junior high
and i walked up to him literally like
[ __ ] 80s movie [ __ ]
and was like let's fight at marco's
house because that was the hill
big shout out to marcos if you're
watching please email me marcos's house
where the ice cream truck was
and literally there was hundreds of
people we fought and he was actually
winning
and i i would argue that i got lucky
slash i just refused to go down like
that he was on top of me
kind of ready to like win the fight and
i kept rocking and i got him
off and as we were both on the ground i
had the leverage and i kicked him so
hard in the face his face exploded
bleeding everywhere
he kind of both stood up off the kick
and he just started crying and ran away
and for next 48 hours was the greatest
moment of my life
like you know but like earlier that
morning was probably the
because of that micro i'll call it a
micro loss because some [ __ ]
we didn't even get into it but he was
definitely pushed me from behind on some
sucka [ __ ] and then he sat on top of me
and they broke it up and i didn't really
have any offense so it's
what about for you six to 16 best moment
in a fight
worst moment because i've never had yeah
worst moment worst
worst moment would probably be um let's
give somebody
have a good moment you're gonna call
them out and be like oh this dude i had
a fight with this dude mark
and um you know mark's last name i don't
know his last name
you know what i love about the world now
if you knew his last name and you shot
him out
it's like his nephew
i had a fight with mark and um but he
liked the girl that i was friends with
i liked it too but i was really a friend
but i did like her
the worst thing here was the worst thing
about it me and him and this is the
honest to god truth
me and him were in high school i was a
freshman
we fought in the basement by ourselves
like you listen i kicked his ass but got
a mark on my face
and everybody thought he went my ass
explain to me how you guys fought solo
in the basement of a house
no no in the basement of the high school
oh
in high school i saw him that's some
real [ __ ] i saw him
and like you know he was talking
something happened one thing and we like
went down a back step
and like we was just down somewhere in
the high school where there was
people and you know we got into a fight
you know and i was kicking them in the
stomach and like i got him
like it was a good fight like i
tightened him up real nice
but how how it however it worked out it
was like i was punching him in his head
i didn't catch him so how it worked out
is
you had a scratch
and then after we're sitting in the
principal's office because security
broke it up
we did that in the principal's office
i'm like yeah yeah and then a dude walks
in he's like
yeah some other guy walks in he's like
yo what's up he said i said yeah man
i just had what was there he said you
look at you you're the one with the
marks on your face
and walked away i'm like oh no so the
whole name like it was crazy
that was a that was the craziest one um
what was the best the best one the best
one had to be like
this is kind of a long story and it's
gonna sound a little crazy
but i was um i was uh i was in red
lobster with my friends right
yep and we was eating and this guy kept
staring at me
so he stared at me for so long that
finally i walked over his table and said
yo you got to get out of the restaurant
how old were you i must have i might
have been a little older than a 16.
i had to be a little older than 16. but
it was ready
wait you already were in your music well
yeah i was already making music because
remember
i made my first song at 16. well that's
what i think that's why i know
so so with the guy with mark i was 14 i
was about 14 with mark
this one i was a little older i want to
say 18. i want to say 18. so you already
i mean because you hit fast and hard so
you yeah
remember there's no social media it's a
little different i remember you know
what i mean
so so you know so i said you gotta leave
you know and he's driving me crazy so
you know maybe i was a little foul for
that so he left
he left it i i actually kicked him out
of the restaurant and went back and
finished my food
so then we me and my friends we driving
down we're driving down the block
towards my house and a guy comes and
he's like trying to pull us up get over
it
get over and get over and he finally
like you know we i pull over
and he's like yo you know you try to rob
my friend i'm like
rob your friend do you know what i do
rob your friend you think i try to rob
we ended up getting in the fight i said
what you want to fight
so you know he thought he was going he
thought he was going to take up for his
man
and he ended up catching the ass
whipping all right let's let's
man so that was a funny moment uh
how do you think you would have done in
this modern music world
soundcloud instagram knowing your
personality
you know you know obviously you had
tenacity because
i would i would have done phenomenal i
believe that
phenomenal i'm just curious how you you
know because obviously i would
i would have just you know if that was
my thing i would have just been rapping
on every instagram page and every
soundcloud
like every moment every time you turn on
the camera you will see me doing
something
you know it's funny because i believe in
volume and i i talk a lot about putting
out a lot of stuff
and i know i know a lot about your
career because you were so in my pocket
you said you sent your your
your demo everywhere right def jam was
like right like like
i sent it to sugar hill i sent it to
enjoy i sent it to tommyboy
um the demo i sent to to def jam
productions because it wasn't a label
yet
and rocket obesity boys heard it he
played it for rick
and that's how i got my break and then
def jam the label was formed
after after i know because i know that
you you and
and bc boys gave them that clout to get
to the next level
mm-hmm that's true and rick rubin's
talent
russell's vision i mean from a year yeah
that was gonna that was gonna happen
anyway you just too happen to yeah so
how does it
feel i think you know it's funny
i know that i know that in it's
it happened for me later it was
different timing but i know when i'm
70 there'll be documentaries there'll be
things that talk about social media's
early days and i'm
i know i'm going to get flavor from that
you know because i've been you know
and so you that's gonna happen for me
later
hip-hop you were very young you were
early and you're still an extremely
young man now but
you know you're getting kennedy awards
you're in hall of fame
you're you're real og and it's like it's
incredible to
live and be a hall of famer
in something that you were there early
[Music]
and and and it's at the scale that it's
at now right you know you think i think
about the nba
like you know it's not that old of a
league and there's
you know i think about bill russell
thinking about like not sold out
stadiums you know and that like no tv
and now like
what it is like how does it feel to be
at such a pedestal as an og
in something that is one of the most
important things hip-hop's one of the
most
important things in the world well it
feels i look i feel amazing because
i um by the grace of god and hard work
and the grace of god i figured out how
to
keep doing what i love right so i didn't
have to sit
i didn't have to get off the train and
watch it drive away
or what you know watching also you also
evolved
yeah and that so that makes a big
difference right it's not like
you're not sitting on the couch and
saying back in 84 this is you know
you mean you mean it's enjoyable but
it's almost like you can't even smell
that rose
because you're still so active i'm so
active and i've expanded my life
to an extent that i'm still like so on
the grind and so heavy and so
deep in what i'm doing um you know i'm
look
there's a there's a thing called the
lindy effect you you know and the lindy
effect is basically things that
have been around will be around so it's
like shakespeare
like um you know eating with a knife and
fork
um wearing a pair of pants a baseball
cap these things have been around
for a long long long time and that bodes
well for the future
so you know um you know when i was a
little kid i always called it stretching
the bubble gum
and then putting another piece of bubble
gum directly in the center before it
before it pops
you know um and so i just keep going
after my dreams i feel good seeing
what's going on
um but i feel like i'm in a position
where i could
if i decide yo ll cool j is coming out
with an album
i know it's going to get a look i don't
i can't tell you it's going to be a
commercial success i can't tell you know
i can't make those kinds of predictions
i can't talk tough but i can tell you if
i say yo
if i drop an album tomorrow people are
going to listen to it
and i mean that's the best thing you
could do for yourself
have you ever been in your life in the
last 15 years because again you've been
doing
incredible things in hollywood and
acting and i'm sure a million other
things we can get into
i always wonder this at any point
cause listen i love how you answer that
you're aware
that you're not in the white hot moment
of
i'm gonna put out an album and it's
young boy nba numbers you know like you
know
you know i know where i'm at do you
ever have you ever in the last 12 or 15
years i'm gonna just use that time frame
said have you wanted that feeling again
of being in the white hottest of the hot
moment
or you feel like you're fulfilled or
you were fulfilled you went and put that
attention elsewhere
and now once in a while you're like yo
let me grab one of these [ __ ] hot
kids and do a collab with them
just for one more take and by the way i
talk about this a lot
i talk to a lot of youngsters and i'm
like yo you should do something you know
you never
they're like i always talk about ogs i'm
like you should do something with diana
ross
you should do something with stevie
wonder and i'm like in the south side of
atlanta in a studio and they don't even
they're like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like
you never know when one of the greats
is just sitting in their mansion saying
you know what
[ __ ] it for six more months i just want
to taste again
what i tasted in 89 when i tasted in 74
when i tasted in 62 i think about that
[ __ ]
well well it's awesome right yeah go
ahead okay great great
i've never asked the og i always tell
the kids i'm like yo cool that you've
got some heat right now
but do something that's just gonna make
your grandmother smile because i always
think an og
a legend is you know if you ask 30 of
them one's ready to do it
and they're just cool to have but i've
never asked the legend
on the other side have you in the last
decade said
man i i might really want to go
uncomfortably contemporary
and and i might want to do something
with the baby
or meg stallion to do that or does that
just never cross your mind
um you know what like the reality is i
would
definitely um consider working with
with a with a young act and with a new
act i don't
see any reason to remove myself from
that i'm not like one of these og's that
sits around
mad about and for me
and for me and i'm sorry to interrupt
and for me and for a lot of people
listening
like if i woke up and saw a young boy in
ll
did a track i'd loot my brain would
break i think that that
that com those kind of combos like gaga
and tony bennett made me smile
yeah yeah i think look look man like
you know there's acts you know like you
know there's all kind of cool acts out
there right
and if it's organic and if we can find
something that
like we feel great about that that we
that we write together or somebody
writes a chorus that we feel is
in a track that really brings it out and
makes it special why not like
i don't need to like i'm not like i'm
not like
allergic to to the new [ __ ] i'm not like
allergic to what's happening
contemporary what's contemporary i'm not
like like at that's not a problem for me
like i enjoy listening to
listening to new acts and young young
artists and
you know like and and listen to them
bridge the gap you know what i'm saying
like
like a prime example like meek mill just
dropped that record with a little dirk
i'm i'm playing that on my channel rock
the bells because i think it's dope
and it's got a lot of melody in it you
know what i'm saying it's not even like
meek is doing his normal spitting
you know rapid fire spitting it's real
melodic but i like the video i like the
song
i play i'm putting it in breaking bells
you know a person you know
so it's like for me whether it's
you know um from from from a billy
eilish all the way to uh
you know to to a baby to a little baby
like with the moment of truth like i pay
attention i love the record he did
about the protest i thought that [ __ ]
was hot i liked the baby's performance
when he was on
on the awards when you know he was
performing with the knee on his neck
like i i pay attention to what's going
on in the world and what what's going
on in our culture like i'm not a guy
that's just like sitting up in the big
house
um you know saying disinterested
or not you know let's talk about that on
the culture let's talk about
the technology side when did the
internet
when did you get excited or when did
they hit your radar
going way back to you know aol or
myspace when did you first kind of
not necessarily know about it but when
maybe even napster given your career
like
like what's some early internet ll
stories of like
i i thought it was [ __ ] i didn't
like it i was mad at napster i got
excited about napster
my space was popping like i didn't take
it serious until
twitter like talk to me about your last
20 years
on the tech culture game yeah well you
know the first if for me it was um you
know quincy jones gave me a book the
road ahead
by bill gates when that came out and i
guess that was in the late 90s maybe
but almost right before 2000 like in
that that window
somewhere in there um and so that kind
of peaked my interest
um i thought limewire you know you know
when limewire came out i was like
i thought i was really curious about
that and was like kind of trying to
figure out searching for music
um i actually i actually
adopted and kind of adapted to the
internet pretty quickly
um in terms of the idea of it i didn't
necessarily dive in
from like as a a user but i was in it
early like in terms of just being
comfortable with it
you know i didn't even fear it you
didn't think it was gonna [ __ ] your
money up
no i didn't but you know at one point at
one point the record companies did gas
me up you know they did gassed me up and
i was down here in front of congress
like yo i'm not sure
like like like because i was gassed up
and you know
understanding that that that that they
were just trying to hold on to some [ __ ]
that was going to go away anyway
they was trying to hold on to a business
model that was no longer
viable you know what i'm saying um and
i've got to go through it
yeah i get it but but but really quickly
i was like
all the way in and then you know i had
on my space page you know what i'm
saying i had a little myspace page
i was into that um you know was there
early for instagram didn't jump on it in
terms of use
but was right when instagram started i
was there
are you on tick tock right now um i do
have a tick tock but i only watch it i
don't really
i haven't done anything it's
entertaining right it's
come on man it's unbelievable i know you
got a tick-tock i often come down
and check yours out as well and um i go
on tick-tock people dancing
i saw i saw a mother and a daughter um
um climbing up climbing a doorway door
frame exercising to it's tricky by run
dmc did you see that i did
you know what i mean like so yeah i'm on
tick tock
um which i need to get more active on it
i'm i'm look
i'm all about like i was on um for the
five minutes it was out
um what was the one periscope was i was
on that one that for five minutes that
was out
um you know all of them all of them
um facebook i'm on facebook i'm on you
know
talk to me about talk to me about
jumping around a little bit
so you you break at 16
talk to me in those first 24 months
because there's a lot of people
listening right now
who are destined and are going to be big
influencers
because the way the world works now you
know
everyone's got at least 15 fans and a
hell of a lot more now because the long
tail of fame is
just like the music industry was trying
to hold on the fame game is
everybody's in play everybody you know
but it's funny but you know everybody's
in play but then it's about your
contribution
period oh talent and the content is the
punch line like the creative is the
variable of success
but everybody's got a shot in a
different way now but i was curious
i was just sitting here listening to you
i'm like let me what do i want to be
selfish
who was the person that was real famous
that you met let's say
in the first two years of your fame
building because you hit that record
came out boom you know like you got some
juice you were like one of those first
15 20 faces
like that really mattered in when the
mtv era
you know kind of really got going you
know yo mtv rap early days did it
like that that pocket you were in that
was 50 names for sure
who's the person you met maybe at the
first award show or in
studio that really like was like
oh [ __ ] like a michael jackson no no
i mean it was diana ross and michael
jackson it was them like
i mean diana ross was the first person
to put me on television
is that right yeah diana ross had a a tv
special on abc
and she gave me my first break to
perform on tv take me that story
how did you find out you were gonna do
that show who called him
you know it was you remember i think i i
i i think i seen her somewhere or
something like that and she was like oh
i want you to do my show i want you to
come on and perform and i was like okay
and then she you know somehow she got
with the uh
the record company and um i ended up
doing it and um so i have
did you have management at that point
i'm you know here's the funny thing
about my career i've had a couple of
managers here and there
um but the reality is um
like you know russell managed me for
five minutes leo matters me for 10
minutes
my dad managed me for 15 minutes this
guy charles managed me for maybe
16 minutes but you know
throughout that whole time i i ended up
self-managing myself because
because in for that period growing up in
hip-hop because
there was nobody who had done it before
all of the managers were either former
rock managers or this type of manager or
plus you had it in you yeah so i just
kind of
took the really like you like you have
like it's how i think about myself
early on people like how are you getting
on who's doing your pr i'm like me
yeah like like i knowing you enough your
entrepreneurial tendencies the way you
move
it just makes sense to me you were
capable of managing yourself
you probably secretly liked it because
you liked the business side of it and
there you are
and then you know ultimately then i got
with chris lighty um at violator
um and claudine was my day to day but
chris was my manager but we
we acted more like partners may he rest
in peace we were more
like it wasn't like i was calling like
chris what should i do
it was more like this is what i'm
thinking what you thinking you know
so yeah i've been you know i kind of
been running my own show for
you know my whole career you know what i
mean being at halftime in your life
because i think that's what people are
very confused right like
we've got a long way to go yeah yeah
yeah what what's at this exact second
what's the thing that's been really
running through your head in the last
call it
six months to a year that you're like i
really want to do this
i mean just this rock the bells platform
man like
building this rock the bells platform
because this rock the bells platform
um is something that
you know one day the youngest kid right
now will be
somebody that will play on rock the
bells like you know rock the bells radio
and the rock the bells.com
platform is not just a place for guys
who started when i started and are my
age now it is
it will keep growing you know we will
support the little waynes we you know
one day
you know you know the everybody that you
named
will be all playing on rock the bell so
it's like i just
like for me just giving people a true
rendition
uh up and and og presenting
the classic hip-hop space to the world
in a way that
is not bitter it's not corny we know
what year it is
we're not [ __ ] delusional i'm just
saying this is some cool [ __ ]
i want you to check it out it's like
basically i'm taking you through
my record collection and my photo album
and my you know all the things i've been
through in my life and showing giving
you some game
you know what i mean that's what rock
the bells is like so um
that's really the thing that i've been
focusing on um and then
you know doing so what about some random
[ __ ] because like
like you're doing that i'm excited about
that i'm glad people are hearing about
that
i'm talking like an astronaut owning a
baseball team um winning an academy
awards thing in your pocket like yeah
random ass [ __ ]
you know one of the things that i try to
really get across to people
is i know who's listening right now is
you're 31
you [ __ ] idiot i say without with all
love
you think you're wrapped up people hello
you know this people think they're done
at 31. they're like
that's [ __ ] funny that's why i'm glad
that you like i love please everybody
understand that reaction people think at
31 like
because they have a kid they have a job
they don't like like they have a
mortgage
like i'm done like people are confused
out here about age
so you know just knowing how alive you
are at 52 to me what i'm curious about
is
you know what's some real [ __ ] that you
like think about like for example for me
ironically you did the same thing
i know i don't even think i know that
i'm gonna make
a big ass dent in film and television
from making shows you know i don't think
i'm gonna act though
i'm not [ __ ] scared but you know like
but i
i just know it i genuinely think i'm
gonna have the number one
ott called netflix hulu amazon show
going i can feel it
it's been written i can taste that [ __ ]
in my mouth
yet that's not something i'm showing a
whole lot yet well it'll be like
and i'm being totally honest gary you
know like
you know see you know
i when i talk about rock the bell see
for most most of the time when people
talk about
what they're doing they're either like a
[ __ ] chill or they're just
they're promo and or they're selling or
like
but you got to remember like this
business that i'm talking about
is the same thing that i did when i was
nine and started writing when i was 12
and i'm really in this and so for me
it's like the idea that i can build
something that two three four hundred
years from now
will have the narrative of hip-hop
be right will be right two three four
five hundred years from now
that's what i'm talking about i'm not
talking about just making a bunch of
money
i do other things i can make money in a
lot of different ways
you know and i say that with humility
but it's true
it's not it's not only about making
money it's about
building something that that means
something like
what i'm saying let's say on this on
this topic because i want to
i want to enjoy this i want to i want to
educate some kids
how underrated is mc life
tell them oh my god educate
educate well mclight mc light was so
good the first time i heard on the radio
um i just turned the [ __ ] off because i
didn't
it made you like [ __ ] you made me
uncomfortable and i was like
that's a girl and she shouldn't sound
that good and i just had to turn it off
you know you know
that it was it was like i just you know
it made me like
uncomfortable because she's so good um i
ended up
writing like her her rhyme on of
self-destruction we did a song of
self-destruction
scott's tape with a razor blade taped to
your collar you know um
um funky first restaurant press ready to
party i wrote that for her
like it was like she was she is like her
voice
her her approach like people should
definitely
dig into m.c light's catalog let's keep
playing this because i think it's gonna
get people pumped about rock the bells
and honestly i'm just now having fun
like
we were just like we're just hanging out
give me give me the same
we're doing 90 seconds with ll here
we're going to play a little game
what about heavy d and the boys heavy d
unbelievable if the history lesson like
funny story or why it's underrated or
how it impacted
play with me here the funniest [ __ ]
about i have look i love having he rest
in peace he was one of the smoothest and
the best
ever the thing would have is don't say a
rhyme around heaven
because you might hear some [ __ ] that
sounds similar next week is that what is
that true
is what i need from you this is
yo i remember going to heaven's house in
mount vernon he's still in this house
he like the way he flipped his basement
when he after he came
out with his salt with mr big stuff and
all that his basement looked like james
bond should live there it was like deep
heavy he walked down the basement you're
like what the
it was like like he took his his
basement
oh my god but half was a really good
thing but it was like
my man half and my man flash gordon them
too
don't say nothing around them it might
show up
for the next one it ain't going to be
what you said but it's going to be like
it's going to be
yo prodigy one of my favorite you know
mc's in
in havoc mob unbelievable you know what
i'm saying um
what did they when you when they were
the t-shirt that prodigies wearing in
the quiet storm oh i think it's the
quiet storm video with kim
i want to say it's that one i gave him
that t-shirt as a gift
just because i was just just loved them
you know what i'm saying and i just
i have a lot of respect for mob deep i
think the way they writ they represented
queens was
unbelie the way they do represent queens
we did a song on my goat album
um cause called queen killer queens you
know what i'm saying
in the queens got the vets it was it was
dope and um
yo i just my the way he wrote um the way
he would
make things rhyme and then not rhyme the
way he would the way he would
play with language play with words
queens get the money long time low cash
you know what i mean like i mean he he
was just
i remember when i was like this guy's
clever i remember using that word
clever but like but he had a way of
sounding authentically tough
that's not easy that's not easy to come
across you could sound
angry on a record that's one thing you
could sound
angry you could sound aggressive
but to be able to to to to talk
to be calm and really sound
authentically tough
um the only two people to me that really
sound like that are
are prodigy and rakim where the person
is not
they're not yelling but they sound
aggressive and tough let's keep this
rock the belt
kind of like little fun game i'm
enjoying this a little bit for my own
self what about epmd these are things
that i just think
the youngsters don't know yeah and under
all time classic
talk we're talking all-time classic talk
right now but i would argue
underrated which is why i love this
without a doubt
epmd is a group that the kid they should
the kids should check out
um you know at first when they first
came out people used to tease him and
say they sounded like
rock him sounded like eric but um
you know the the the beat selection that
eric sermon
would make um me and paris um would
always get into conversations about
money and real
estate and [ __ ] and be sitting around
telling my real estate we did a record
together called rampage
um it's a record called rampage the kids
should check out
epmd rampage um featuring ll cool j it's
one of both of ours
our best classics um it's um
dope and they just like they came from
long island epmd is from long island so
um they you know in long island you know
and rock him is from long island as well
he's from wine dance which is right up
down the block from north babylon like
you could literally walk down his
neighborhood from where i lived in north
babylon so it's like
it was it was a vibe it was a vibe epmd
just was so
official what about what about something
that was like a hot minute
that like just had a fever pitch to it
i'd love to get your perspective you're
in a different part of your career at
this point what about foxy brown's
moment
well i launched foxy brown right like
you know the i shot your record i put
you know we put
fox well chris and the trackmasters put
foxy on the record and um when i heard
it i didn't object
i was like yeah let her let her stay let
her stay they didn't do it they didn't
ask they just said yo listen to this
and i heard it and i said go ahead let
it let her rock and she um
she was fired that
like it just was like fever pitch with
her solid definitely solid definitely
dope voice
um definitely like you know like
tomboyish but
but feminine it was like she had a good
she was she was magic you know she is
you know very talented act
um you know they yeah you know what i'm
saying but there's a lot of talented
acts out there now like you know
you think about a kendrick and you think
about you know the way he plays with
rhythms when he with his voice
even somebody made piece like nipsey you
know
so intelligent you know i'm saying so
smart so brilliant i know you were close
with him
i saw different times you spoke with him
i mean so that's like kind of like that
mid-generation he was
very very special um what the baby's
doing now is very
he's very clever you know he just
understands the world
talk to me about talk to me not to cut
off because i could talk about
the baby for a hot minute but talk to me
about
i like what you said about mc light and
i don't want to run out of time without
asking you
on that same kick what was what was the
track the record that you heard
that literally was the biggest quantum
jump for you
like from your you know one man's point
of view like
you heard it and you were like oh my god
did anything stop you in your no no yeah
my uzi weighs a ton by public enemy
um my uzi weighs to tell by public
remember do you remember actually
100 i remember [ __ ] i'm
you know i'm in the parking lot of white
castle with the jeep
with the seat leaned back with my man
and that [ __ ] came on the [ __ ]
one of the mixes of the radio or
something and that's it he said he said
you know
um
you know my uzi was a tongue hold it now
get get up get down that [ __ ] was like
my uzi wizard
i mean that [ __ ] was like yo me and my
man was like what the [ __ ]
and here's the funny [ __ ] rick rubin had
just asked me a few months later yo
i got this group in public enemy of you
know i'm thinking about putting out if i
could buy a song from them
um would you want to perform it and i
was like i write my own [ __ ]
and i still stand by that but i kind of
should have took that
that [ __ ] record was so cold yo
when i heard
my uzi weighs a ton that [ __ ] was like
shape-shifting
i haven't felt that yet like that [ __ ]
was like
because the wave the bomb squad hank
shockley and
eric sadler the way him the chuck and
all them the way they've worked with
that
in the way they played with technology
because that was the first time
that somebody really took advantage
of technology well took it to another
level molly did it in a different way
with the sampling
but they took it to a whole other level
you know
um molly kind of when he was doing some
of those bismarck records
those were moments too like make the
music with your mouth and um
and um rhyming with the bit like some
well make the music with your mouth and
the other wrecking um yes you're all
into nobody beats the biz
those were kind of like quantum they
they moved it the needle
like maybe three three three men you
know three points up
but [ __ ] public enemy was like a
hundred you know that [ __ ] was like
it just it was out of control and i
think that um
look that's what you want to do with art
right that's what you want to do with
music that's what you want to do in your
business
like it's just like the dude who made
the 10x book right about 10x
that's what that's what they did they
10xed the creative
the sonics they tend to yes when you
think about success
you've been around a lot of success in
your life now
you know in a lot of different genres
business hollywood music hip-hop new
york la the world
you know and then all the successful
people that you know that nobody knows
of whether
a real estate or a lawyer or right
for the kids that are listening and and
the kids i mean a 62 year old who might
have gotten motivated and said you know
what i do have 30 more years to do
something i'm going to go do this thing
what are the now that you you know
you've always been a wise kid because
your grandpa passed it on you know you
probably just you know
had that in you what's like a wise
thought
around the common bonds of success like
what do you what are the themes that you
see
well first thing really stand out for
you when i set up that question
well first the first thing i have to
think is you know for that 62 year old
dreams don't have deadlines they got to
understand that
you know [ __ ] a huge man colonel
sanders started kentucky fried chicken
when he was 65.
cornelius vanderbilt started his
railroad
company at 80. right cindy frank sidney
frank who started grey goose was in the
70s
okay so you feel me and there's a
million dollars like that feel you i'm
[ __ ] convinced
i i feel like i'm gonna do a [ __ ] i'm
going to drop a [ __ ] bomb
in my 50s 60s 70s and 80s a new box how
i feel
that's how i feel you know i'm going to
take the world and kick it in the ass
and then give it a nice pat on the butt
on the on the back like you did that kid
in the
in the in the basement school but you
know what just like that fight you had
there's gonna be a scar in your face
well that you know that comes with the
territory but what i would say the
common themes of success the common
themes of success
are um the things that you do
in the valley get you to the peak and
the things that you do in the peak
can either extend the peak or take you
back to the valley
right so you know um you know the peaks
and valley part of it
it's very important to understand that
part of it the other thing i think is
really important
is being able to manage your moods mood
management is very important because
your mood a lot of times is going to
dictate not only how you feel about what
you're trying to do but how you feel
about yourself
do you feel that you stay in the middle
because i cuz that's the goal that
that's what i think
people see my energy and they're
confused i'm [ __ ] zen as [ __ ] out
here yeah yeah
well enthusiasm is enthusiasm
is not is misunderstood like what are
they called there's the stockdale
paradox right you
i'm sure you know about the stockdale
paradox from google actually i i don't
know i don't know the cocktail paradox
basically says
um um you're gonna be you're gonna
be be completely optimistic but while
confronting the brutal facts
yes that's how i feel i'm i'm practical
what i call myself is
i'm i'm practically optimistic like i
i know exactly what's happening but i'm
[ __ ] out here and i'm not delusional
they're like gary you're too optimistic
i'm like what the [ __ ] does that mean
well well like you can make it confused
out here
but we can make it easy for the
youngsters as listen i'll make it even
easier gary's just like playing a
basketball game
because you down by seven don't mean you
ain't enjoying yourself and into the
game and playing hard
i watched i watched reggie bro i watched
reggie miller make me [ __ ] cry
when he did that dude the game was over
but it wasn't over and i don't
understand how people don't understand
how that
is and i i can't get people out of this
i'm fighting out here like
crazy ll people 18 22
30 34 confused as [ __ ]
well the reason they're confused is
because one they're doing they're
comparing themselves to other people too
much yes
yes you can't you cannot you know you've
got you know
you know life
life is an odd thing but the the
you can't treat it like it's a
tournament it's
your life and the the metrics for
success
are different you know in the bible
there's that parable of the talents
right so one guy got one talent one guy
got a couple of talents
one guy got you know uh four times do
you think
the world is abundant that like nobody
else's winnings comes from you
hundred percent yeah that's the one
people it's not a zero-sum game see
that's the other part right that's why i
root for winners hundred percent well
that's what i'm telling you
yeah that's what i was telling you i
can't so it's like yeah
it did there is abundance but you got to
see it that way right like
like you got to believe that it's out
there for you but
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
because when you believe it's out there
for you you go out there and get it 100
percent
if you like i was in the hood i mean
when i was in the hood like
just growing up you know that was i
would tell dudes like yo i'm going to be
we're running them as adults i'm gonna
get and they'd be like come on man ain't
nothing out here for look where they at
man look where we at
[ __ ] that yeah the game's listen if you
think it's over
it is actually over it is real if you
think it's over
because your older brother or sister
aren't winning and they told you or your
parents or the neighborhood or your
cousin
or somebody on the internet if you think
it's over i got some real news for you
it
actually is over and you know what to
really make it to really make it simple
the bottom line is you
have to believe in yourself and believe
in the beauty of your dreams
and you have to take a deep breath take
a deep breath
and go for it have you seen people
who had the unfortunate situation of not
believing in themselves because their
parents
got hurt
but you know what you know like that's a
matter of
getting out of your comfort zone right
if you if your comfort zone
unfortunately if you're you're you know
if the word is unlucky or whatever words
you want to use
if you if your comfort zone is i would
say
a place where your your default setting
is a is a place of failure
then you have to be able to get out of
that
that comfort zone spending time with
people
that are cheering for you can make that
happen
i think i think i think that can be part
of it but the other part of it is you
have to be
you have to be doing the work that makes
that
cheering realistic
like you know what i mean like you could
cheer for me like i could be stretching
my legs standing next to usain bolt
and you can be cheering for me all you
want gary but the reality is he's going
to smoke my ass when we get on that
track
you know what i mean so so one it's
about
being realistic about what you're trying
to accomplish and then two
yes you want to be surrounded by people
who aren't downers like
you know i remember when my um um you
know
when when simone was um um she was going
through her um
she was she had a bout with cancer in
her leg and she had she needed to beat
the cancer a lady came to our house
right to visit
and she was i just brought someone home
from the hospital lady came to my house
and she walks in my foyer she's crying
and [ __ ] i said
you gotta go get the [ __ ] out of here we
gotta go she was
she was like she was an older lady
that's not helping all that boohoo [ __ ]
you know that harbors
other kinds of emotions you're full of
[ __ ] go ahead like
you know you got to deal with your [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah you're
bringing that on
yeah so i would tell people look just
stay encouraged and believe in yourself
damn and if you look michael jordan make
every shot lebron didn't make every shot
look how many championships lebron
didn't win
but he didn't stop trying and that's why
he's phenomenal now that's why he's a
man that we can respect and a guy that
we can look at as an icon
because he didn't give up and change the
script
yeah i you know we're using somebody
who's iconic and
you know what about just looking at life
differently maybe you're not
destined to be a tremendous accumulator
of
money but maybe you can be a tremendous
human beings to others
can i say something to that guy people
got to understand is that
what it really is about is knowing your
value
it's not about money only right like
everybody has their place um you know
you know you know madonna didn't make
the same money that zuckerberg did
she still made a contribution to the
world through her art
um you know you and i grew up around
neighborhoods where the
the old man on the block was the wise
one who helped a lot of kids not get
into dumb [ __ ]
who only made 27 000 a year but their
contribution
was they genuinely helped 2700 people
have a better life and to you know and
to me
that's where people get [ __ ] up they
look at the one percent of the one
percent of the one percent of the one
percent of the one percent
and then they're like confused out here
like well because they get because
like see the thing i think with people
what people don't understand is that
if you really know your value and if you
always look to make a contribution
you can't you know success is gonna come
it's gonna come and and however there
comes
you know look i always tease like a lot
of my rich friends and when i say rich
friends people hear me say that they're
like well what's wrong
but i'm like guys that are weight like
100 x
times richer than me it's like dude
a lazy boy what can you really do beyond
your chair and your remote
like you ain't doing [ __ ] the only
difference is you got a plane
but other than that you got you got the
remote and you're doing this
and you got your lazy boy and you're
eating so let's
it's not that complicated people
shouldn't get caught up in only money
money money money
you're a valuable human being regardless
of that
what's the impact you're making make
exactly what's the impact and what makes
you
what makes you happy like bro i swear to
god i literally today because it's
saturday
what said man i can't wait to go garage
sailing
yeah i know that you're into that i love
you you know what i do you know what my
my pastime is books right i love that
which is like so foreign to me because i
don't
i realize i don't have reading
comprehension i love books good for you
like
i'm like you can really get down to read
a [ __ ] book huh like i read
like dude that's all i do i like i when
i work out
i play audio books and have music
underneath it like
damn like i'm like a book guy like every
house i have
every spot like there's books everywhere
like i'm just always into books like
books is like i like my idea of a
unbelievable date
is just to have a hoodie on loki and
just be [ __ ] walking around in barnes
and noble like just staring at books
even though i got audio books and i got
a kindle and i got all that [ __ ]
but i'm just saying like i like books
like i'm actually
like like i named myself hello cool j
because
i'm a [ __ ] nerd mm-hmm
you know what i mean like books is the
thing that books is the thing that turns
me into like
that's much like it that's it's
incredible way to end this because i
gotta run i apologize thank you so much
al for your time
love if you did not listen to that last
minute and understand everything
can be wrapped up in it if you
understand yourself
and you have self-awareness and you
don't understand that there's a million
ways to play it out here
this man this man right here winning
impacting happiness
this man probably read more books in the
last week than i've read in my life
i don't know how many but i read a lot
though i've read like eight books in my
life but you know what i also do larry
i'll take one book and read it
over and over for two or three years yes
it's like getting a black belt in the
book get it everybody listen l everybody
does it different here's the bottom line
figure your [ __ ] out how you do it
there's a million ways to slice it
you and i slice it different we have
commonalities we have differences
just love yourself and then you can love
everybody else l thank you so much bro
peace faith in god love you man love you
g peace
youtube bocha what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you